y'all ready to see some hot ps5 versus  ps4 pro loading time tests  well before we start keep in mind these  tests are based on the most recent  versions  of these games at the time of this video  in the future these games  might receive ps5 specific patches  further enhancements to them  such as destiny 2 which is getting one  in december  we've added the patch number to make it  crystal clear which version of the game  is being tested after watching this why  not check out our comparison of loading  times for the ps5 and the xbox series x  alright enjoy  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  do  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you